thank you
all right Tyler
hi Tyler where'd you grow up where are
you from originally Nashville Tennessee
Nashville and tell me about your family
man there's five kids we're all pretty
wild each one more so than the last we
come from
my parents were really conservative
they're both Physicians they met at
Vanderbilt like I think they they had
that whole Southern je ne sais quoi and
I think they planned probably like each
children each child being born like uh
actually three years almost to the date
afterwards all four out of the five are
Aquarius which means my parents were
only having sex in April which is really
weird so but that's just to paint a
little picture as far as just like uh
the culture at the time growing up in
Nashville is really cool though I mean
the music all around us uh food like it
was just like it was a really [ __ ]
cool excuse me can I curse you can it's
a really cool spot to grow up um
especially like looking back at it uh 30
years later but um
yeah I mean we're kind of waspy they put
us in private schools each and every one
of us I ended up I was kind of like I
was second born I ended up from sixth
grade through 12th I spent schools I
finally got to go to public school I
convinced him it took me like 10 years
to convince him but I finally got to go
to public school and I switched schools
every year from 6 through 12 twice and
12 so I ended up going to a lot of
schools growing up um would you describe
your childhood in general
we didn't really need anything uh my dad
was a heck of a provider but that's all
he was a mom was like Mom and Dad
um
really overbearing
um so much love that she didn't know
what to do with it so it came out in a
lot of like controlling manipulative
ways my dad wasn't ever there like I I
didn't speak to my dad like we lived in
the same house but he's just not an
interpersonal type of dude like there's
no getting to know the guy he's a he's
from an Army Family he grew like lived
in 30 different countries so uh
he just wasn't there man so it was like
my mom and and the kids and uh
um I mean we were like all into sports
or music I grew up playing piano and and
percussion uh as did some of my siblings
but uh yeah I mean again like we were
none of us got really close because we
were all always at a different point in
uh in our life like as far as just like
grade wise my older brother my dad were
like nasty uh Angry
um so there was just like a lot that if
anything it was either my mom was too
overbearing or my dad and brother were
just screaming and that was really it so
I kind of just always found solace and
Solitude like Outdoors or I had like a
lot of outlets like to be creative and
like just to like get by growing up so
just really shelter that was the
childhood what kind of kid were you in
high school
uh kind of like the class clown didn't
really fit in so I was kind of putting
on a lot of hats uh
I'm really my tongue's really sharp so I
was like kind of cruel like just to be
funny or like try to fit in with certain
people so I made a lot of friends really
easily especially because I was like
switching schools like every every year
but um I think just as my father I
wasn't able to like really get that
close to people too which is probably
one of the contributing factors to me
um what do you think the end effect is
of having a father like that
um
now that you're an adult
yeah my relationships with men are weird
um
almost non-existent I always get along
better with females
um
I just don't know how to
I didn't know how to be like a like a
man like when I was in high school you
know I just didn't have a a teacher and
like my older brother was just absent
too he took off early and did his own
thing so I didn't have like a coach you
know what I mean
um what'd you want to do after you got
out of school
so I started off in music at Belmont in
Nashville
always wanted to be an architect I grew
up like grabbing the Home Market
magazines from the grocery stores and uh
like drawing what I thought the house
should look like or what the landscape
should look like so I was unaware of a
landscape architecture growing up or
like getting in closer to college
um so I I switched from music production
to the School of Architecture and then
found landscape architecture and that
was kind of like where I thrived man
like I got a bachelor landscape
architecture it came with a price I uh
it took me eight years to finish
undergrad because I lost my fiance a
week before I graduated to a drunk
driver so like from that point that was
like I'm sorry from that point on like
set like a
the things that got set motion were
pretty [ __ ] crazy
um
yeah I'm sorry man I'm not going to get
emotional about that it was about 11
years ago but that was a catalyst for uh
what would be the next 10 years in like
my last decade
um which I heard about derail your life
so let me just a quick side note my I
was sheltered and my brother and sister
right below me gotten a Narcotics
um through a music scene like at a
younger age than I did so when I lost my
fiance I had dabbled I got a ecstasy it
like New Year's just to be fun like
growing up like that was like the extent
of it but uh I got heavy in the uh
opiates and and alcohol uh from that
point on the first time I ever took it
had a heart attack the night after she
passed and uh and uh had it that started
a wild ride man um it's been it's been a
12-year Battle of uh
of trying to find whatever the [ __ ] I
think I'm supposed to do
um I've had a lot of success in a lot of
different areas which we'll probably get
to but um I wasn't prepared for that man
like when I was going my cat either uh
was at the vet or my grandparents were
on vacation as in like my parents didn't
tell us that like death was a thing so I
was not prepared in the least for that
experience and it was uh that was for
you I was 24. and she was she was 21.
yeah
damn that's horrible
yeah I didn't uh
from that yeah I so I started seeking
after that I mean
um I started seeking uh I did a lot of
different things I uh the first thing I
actually did was I was encouraged to go
to Mexico and try Ayahuasca ibogaine
it's like this like weird desert like
ritual and ended up meeting them
this wild British Italian chick here
they didn't take me to Europe for like
nine months but uh yeah again I just
wasn't prepared for that like at all so
uh
I can't remember if there was like a
second part of that question but
no just you know that's such a derailing
oh my God yeah absolutely like like I
said it took uh eight years for me to
get back on track to then uh complete
that degree which I was finally able to
do but um
I have been my the past decade's been
riddled with uh
breeding Fierce resentment uh tearing
down the roof overhead building up a
bright outlook for myself
um uh finding new relationships Burning
Bridges giving away things uh losing
things and actually man I don't think
I've ever lost anything I think I've
always chose to seek pleasure as like a
reward and um
and in doing so
I can't control emotional natures and I
lose um
and I like give all these things away
that are like good and great and holy uh
to get high like and that's me man I'm
like I uh it's I'm not embarrassed to
say so um it was my it saved my life
Drug's not going to save my life at the
point I guess at that point but um
I have just been like I kind of I missed
the manual you know I mean like my dad
didn't give me the manual growing up so
um
I've been derailed on and off for the
better part of yeah more than a decade
now
um I moved out to California after that
experience I've been out here for about
11 years now
um
where are you staying now uh Dana Point
I have a beautiful new fiance
um
took me about that many years I met her
two years ago we just celebrated two
years about two weeks ago it took me
that many years to even give myself a
shot and um
and like look and like having something
like that again because like
my fear and losing almost anything
especially something like that is just
so overpowering that it it uh it bars me
from a lot of things like I uh I miss
out on experiences or opportunities or
choose to say no or just stay inside or
like depression is like a like a
comfortable like dark situation where
um
because of like fear
based on my childhood and what happened
with uh my fiance
I just I just don't do I just don't do
life I just don't life well man like I
really don't but again like I said I can
build up something like really quickly I
like tearing it down too but um
I
I've been able to help a lot of people
through
my experiences like I wish I could I
wish I could
there's so much anecdotal evidence of
the past decade is suggested like I have
a wild story I'm a cool story and I have
like a lot of ways I can help somebody
and that's when life gets good man is
when I'm able to like
try and help like the next man but uh
what are you hoping to do now
so I own a company
um I I it took a long time to do that I
uh I had the courage to do so I left La
when covet hit because it La got like
apocalyptic and weird and people were
like skating down the 405 and I moved to
the South and uh created an LLC
um
with having built rapport with like
several you know in my industry in the
creative industry it's like it's it's
kind of like a service too I mean I'm
the landscape architect so I had already
had some Network to go off of like
whether it be my parents or people like
from school or my alma mater like so
covet my covet year was a blessing like
that that that that that kind of
catapulted me into a a different version
of myself that I never knew was possible
I still own that company I'm very lack
of days equal I've done three projects
in the past nine months so I'm kind of
just like surfing right now
um are drugs a part of your life still
they are yeah
they are I uh
I ended up getting it to a point where I
stayed away from them for three years uh
a little over three years and when I
lost that time or gave away that time
you know I can't put together 30 days
um so I'm still risking
I do I do things that like significantly
diminish cognitive functions so I'm uh
I'm playing I'm rolling the dice every
day any day that I decide the night not
be sober I'm rolling the dice and uh
opiates opiates crack cocaine
um Xanax fentanyl crack cocaine and
Xanax
and that's what I uh that's a common
combination it seems that's what I
choose to uh
go after
um
my fiance has no idea where I am right
now I'm not supposed to be where I am
right now uh physically mentally
spiritually whatever but um
yeah man I can't uh I'll probably end up
I have a kind of a pessimistic
uh but a little bit often yeah I have a
I'm pessimistically hopeful that I'm
gonna live but I don't think I'll live
much longer than I am right now to be
honest with you I don't want to be drab
or like depressing or like that dark on
this web but um
that's just like an intuitive that's
just like a guttural feeling is that
like if I continue on my path like
my life's over you know what I mean what
do you think was a bigger factor in that
Outlook uh your childhood with your
two parents or the the loss of your
fiance your first fiance I think um
I think they were all contributing
factors uh the death uh really opened
the door
um
but man I uh I've sought out pleasure
before I knew what drugs and alcohol
were I was seeking out pleasure anyway I
could just like exercising on a runner
Tire like a new relationship or taking a
trip so I've always sought pleasure but
um
are you ADHD yeah yeah I don't take meds
anymore for that but uh that was
probably my first experience with like
God with like a medicinal like stimulant
so or like uh legal stimulants um
yeah
so the drugs are kind of self-medicating
a bit
at this point buddy to be honest with
you
um I use against my will it's the nature
of the Beast I uh I consider myself to
be an alcoholic or I subscribe to the
fact that I have the mind of an
alcoholic and I don't know if any if you
or anybody watching like knows about
that but uh
in in essence my my midbrain my
thinking's [ __ ] up so I I use the same
brain to try to get out of the problem I
got myself into the problem with and I
just stay in a cycle of was anyone in
your family that was yeah a couple of my
siblings suffer from the same disease uh
aunts and uncles my parents
damn dude they said they should but they
don't they don't um
yeah it's in the field I don't know like
if it's Genetically speaking like have a
Native American in us um or
again I was just pretty dis
yeah I had a predisposition in so many
different areas that um it's hard for me
like in hindsight it's hard for me to
just like pick one I think I just had
all trauma all over the place instead of
just one big thing that happened to me
this lifestyle
is it something that you recognize as
taking you down with your relationships
in your career or or do you see it as
something yeah and I think I think
I think when I make the choice because
from a silver state of mind and body I'm
always making the choice to come up and
do the gritty things that I like to do
um
I think that uh
I think that it's to subconsciously I
think it's to push away from all that
the good stuff I don't think I know how
to like succeed or like I don't think I
like prefer I don't know man it's really
weird you have a self-destructive Street
yeah and it's like my my introspective
nature like only comes out like when I'm
prompted like like right here you know
what I mean like I don't walk around
just like I ignore everything that I
probably should
um kind of like take into account as far
as decision making goes as an adult or
like as a child or you know what I mean
or like as a lover
um I I think it's just it's just fear
man it's just fear and they just try to
ignore it it's always fear it's [ __ ]
always fear hundreds of forms of fear
dude but it's it's all the same thing
it's all the same thing and uh I try and
reinvent the wheel
um even though I have things that I know
work for me
I'm always seeking something new and uh
and more will be revealed as far as like
why I mean so when that moment comes
let's say it's Friday night and you're
you're sitting there
and the Temptation comes to oh I'll
order the Uber right away
I won't even drive anymore because I've
totaled too many cars I've gotten pulled
over too many times I just get in the
Uber is there like a devil on your
shoulder and an angel on the other one
saying yeah do it and I'm so good at
this point just at this point I am so
good or at least well-versed in in
ignore completely uh compartmentalizing
the angel and letting it like letting
the devil just do its thing or like I'm
not blaming it on my good and you I
don't think there's like good or bad I
think there's a
there just is and then and and I choose
the uh I choose the easier easier way
sometimes is it is it the fun of it the
excitement the adrenaline the it's uh
it's adrenaline it's exciting it's like
the grit it's like the like you're not
supposed to do it it's like the sneaking
around it's like I'm very crafty and you
know what I mean like I think it's uh
because once I start doing the drugs I'm
not I'm miserable I don't I feel awful
what is the Angel boring too boring for
you it's a little boring but then I turn
to the angel and then I'm like you know
I mean I've got so much potential to go
in any direction and I'll go so hard in
either direction but I just can't seem
to like my my road is is is very windy
you know there's no straight path for me
dude yeah
you can't find a career choice or maybe
I make good money doing what I do
um but the money is dangerous for me
yeah
I finally got to a point where
if I were to put as much effort into
doing the drug if I put as much effort
into like my work and I'd be [ __ ]
killing it man but I just uh I'm not
sure that's just not what I'm choosing
right now I know I don't know
it's unfortunate my family's written
their eulogy they don't really talk to
me right now because they're scared
they're scared I just have my fiance and
like clients and support and some
friends but does your fiance know the
truth of it all
she doesn't understand she doesn't she
doesn't know I'm doing it right now she
doesn't know um
I think her Hope In Me Is Bigger Than My
Hope in me but it keeps me going on
she's one of she's probably a pretty big
contributing factor to me being like
alive and well and um fiscally or
morally responsible right now uh as much
as I'm not being so but um yeah she uh I
can't be honest with her for the life of
me I can't
what are you afraid of with being honest
with her
um
I think I just I'm I'm in fear that I
just that I hate losing things
and I'm I'm in fear that she'll just run
which she probably should I mean
Fearless she'll go
because I don't want to be alone man
like I think I see a thriving
connections and and seek connection
and uh
and yeah I give all those away buddy
you're looking for love
yeah in all the wrong places it doesn't
come in a crack pipe
doesn't come in a crack pipe
who's your favorite memory as a child
playing tennis
my dad that was the one cool thing about
me that I do remember him always always
showing up at like uh
uh
like my games he was he was really cool
about that it's really cool about that
um that means a lot to a kid
seriously it does yeah
yeah the one time my dad showed up to
one of my little league games I hit a
home run oh yeah did you say the only
time or the one time that was the only
time I think I'd hoped really
explained buddy Little League's fun
um that and I think just growing up
around such like talented people in
Nashville
it was really that was a
that's important too yeah
absolutely I think I've just uh who is
your most important role model
as a kid
I don't think I found a role model until
I found a a mentor
and when I started
in the school of landscape architecture
I had this Taiwanese Mentor who taught
me how to draw
and uh he kind of just taught me how to
live dude like I learned a lot I'll
forever be grateful for this man and he
totally changed the the Outlook and
chords of my life and like he changed
the way I like looked at myself in the
mirror and
um
yeah but it took 20 20 years to find a
mint or orderlies for for the student to
be ready you know what I mean so
wasn't in my family
or my immediate surroundings so
yeah I was just kind of an isolated like
shy random kid so took a long time for
me to grow up a little bit
is your IMO to go on vendors and then
kind of straighten out and go back and
forth yeah I go really hard for three
weeks and ruin everything and then I'll
straighten out for now it's it used to
be six months or a year but now I'll
straighten out for three weeks you know
I can't it vacillates it's a
it's unfortunate because it's not what I
want and I'm a prisoner I'm out in my
own mind and uh
and uh and I can't seem to stay sober
can you imagine anything that might get
you to change that behavior
where you like to stick with the age
yeah advice
yes and that's always
unselfish and self-seeking in so many
ways that like
when I'm able to be selfless or like if
I'm connected to like
my girl or like whatever Powers it be or
the mighty Rhythm like I'm kind of
spiritual so if I'm connected and I'm
like helping others I'm straight like
life is great
um pieces like
there's like a joy or like the veil gets
lifted enough for me to see that there's
like a better simpler more beautiful way
of life but um if I choose to uh uh
self-seek dude then
life is a
untenable and I like the Constitution
for suicide so uh I get I get caught in
the Whirlwind of uh maybe hoping that
the drugs will kill me and I don't know
I really don't
it's weird
do you think you have a suicidal streak
I've tried a couple of times
yeah with drugs
with drugs yeah first time was in the
year 2000
and the last one was January of last
year
I always think I plan it out just right
but for some reason I just I just
there's a there's there's probably like
a bigger plan for me man uh from these
powers that be and uh and uh I just keep
squandering it the opportunity so have
you ever been on psych medications
yeah I'm on psych meds right now yeah
um General like major depressive
generalized anxiety uh I started seeing
therapists when I was eight so this is
like a 30-year Battle of like playing
hide and go seek by myself
it's weird are you drugs something that
alcohol would not be a good idea to
combine with oh all of my oh yeah all
the bottles say uh they either have a
skull and cross stones on them or they
say don't mix it out you'll do it
sometimes do what alcohol
what about it you'll combine alcohol
with yourself oh all the time yeah yeah
all the time
which can be dangerous yeah I think it's
just a feeble skirt like I'm just like a
scared boy and like a 36 year old body
you know I don't know just feeble
attempts of
trying to like just feel feel different
and feel different real quick dude so
what's your biggest regret
treat my parents like a checkbook not
giving them the opportunity to have a
son not given
robbing them of so many countless nights
of sleep and peace and
honestly it's it's the way I've done my
parents that's my biggest regret
yeah
they didn't deserve that
they don't deserve it
gives you meaning in your life
um my
my relationships do
um
even if I've
hinted that they don't uh my current
relationship
um my my creativity and like my my
outlet at work and like or like a
god-given talent to do something and uh
and seeing other people like
just seeing people grow like seeing
seeing seeing a group of people like
grow with each other that gives me
inspiration
yeah just because again I didn't I
didn't I didn't have the where was all
to look at look for that when I was
growing up and I didn't have teachers so
it's just watching people like uh
succeed and Thrive and and love and help
each other and that's that's what gives
me inspiration yeah do you have good
friends
I do and they'd be a hell of a lot
better if um if I if I gave more myself
to them but um
yeah all the people in my life right now
that support me treat me better than I
think I deserve and uh that's also
really inspiring for me so um
who knows man like maybe I'm maybe this
weird incident of me walking in here and
being right here right now like uh
changes the course of the next
month year 10 years yeah I've seen it
happen yeah yeah because again like I
said I don't like walk around thinking
about these things I ignore it and uh
how many opportunities do we have in
life to really unload like this
I've had uh 27 Hospital overdoses uh
plenty more where I wasn't found by a
medical bird you know what I mean so
I've been giving away too many chances
and uh
I've utilized them too don't get me
wrong I'm not just like a scumbag just
walking around just taking taking but uh
yeah I uh I've been given
I've been given a lot of Grace a lot of
Grace
as far as like opportunities go so and
Tyler what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
impermanence
two yeah two things so the fact that
nothing lasts forever the good or the
bad so that's the awesome part is the
bad [ __ ] doesn't last
the good stuff doesn't last forever
either some of it could be I can have a
lifelong friend but um so it's
impermanence and realizing that like
pain isn't a punishment and pleasure is
not a reward and I grew up for a long
time thinking
that like life was doing it to me like
if I was rewarded you know what if if I
had pleasure it was because I was being
rewarded or if something happened if
there was pain it's because I was being
punished and that shit's not it like
that's just that's just the cyclical
nature of like being a human that's just
uh the epitome of being a or like The
Human Experience so I finally knew that
uh
when especially when I lost uh her a
long time ago to the drunk driver if I
knew that that those feelings wouldn't
last I'm sure she probably wouldn't have
gone and did all the things that I did
it took me a long time to realize that
impermanence isn't isn't a or is like a
like a hell of a core value of mine so
that's great
Tyler thank you so much for sharing your
story yeah
thanks man I wish you uh all the luck in
the world thank you I appreciate that
yeah
good to be here Good to Be Alive yeah